Oh, sorry.
I forgot.
Sorry, that's a screenshot.
Let me turn that off.
I forgot I had that on.
I was like, whoa, whoops.
I'm sorry, I just woke up not okay right now.
I just woke up ten minutes ago because I needed nap time.
Hello, good morning, I'm back.
MrBrokenBot, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, waking up just minutes before stream doesn't help with your brain bug.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Gus, thank you for the magenta super.
Hi Doki, you most likely won't be able to read the chat in battle, so here is the back seating.
Dodge, dodge, attack now.
Stop attacking and dodge.
Run, heal.
Dodge, attack.
You should have dodged that.
Watch out for the cliff.
Have fun.
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, so, um, for those who are wondering about my brain fog, it is...
Oh, sorry, I'm on my recording settings.
Oh my god, I'm all over the place.
I...
Okay, okay, now, now things are okay.
Uh...
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Too much text.
All you need is spam R1.
Ah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
No, not, not spam.
All I need is a message and praise.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
And then I can take everything.
Sorry, now, now!
Now, everything should be okay now.
Um, okay, I don't know if my brain fog is still there.
It doesn't help that I literally just woke up.
Uh, because, um... Um, um, I was very, I don't know, I was just very tired today because dad keeps, like, being a little fucking asshole.
I gave him bed privileges today.
Like, my bed privileges for, like, you know, for today because I was very weak.
Um, and then he, like, jumped off my bed.
Not once, but twice.
So, so I had, like, fear because he was doing so well.
I, like, let him, let him on my bed, like, this morning.
Uh, because he was, like, whining and stuff.
So I was just like, okay, I'll, I'll, like, let you up in the bed.
Um, because he whines less when he's sleeping next to me.
And then, you know, he walked up and walked down from the actual, uh, from, like, from, with the stairs.
So I was like, okay, because I wanted to test him.
I was like, alright, will you use the stairs when you go down?
And he was like, yes, I will.
I definitely will.
Please.
Please, sir, can I please be on the bed?
And I was like, okay, you've proved to me that you can use the stairs when you go down.
So, I'll let you up.
And then, silly me, he conned me.
He conned me into using my bed.
Because the moment he was, like, he was there for, like, 15 minutes.
And then he, like, jumped off the bed.
And I was like, are you fucking, for no reason!
He just, like, jumped off the bed.
And then he, like, and then I saw that he did that.
And I was like, no!
So then I pushed his stairs away.
But, obviously, it wasn't too far away.
Because I laid back down, closed my eyes, and then he was next to me.
And I was like, how?
And I was just like, like, I don't know if he takes this as, like, a form of entertainment.
Because he was like, I broke my back once doing this.
But she can just fix me.
So, there's no consequences now.
And so, it's because I didn't push the stairs far enough.
So, he climbed up on the stairs at the top.
And then he, like, used the stairs as, like, a ram to, like, jump to the bed.
Because there was, like, a little gap between the bed and the stairs.
Because I didn't push it.
I didn't push it too far enough!
So, then he was like, you think this tiny gap is gonna stop me?
So, I assume he just jumped over the tiny gap.
I don't know.
Because I was, like, closed my eyes.
And then I felt him next to me.
He just wants to feel alive again, you know?
The risk of breaking his back just makes him feel alive.
And then he jumped off the bed again.
Again.
But he didn't do it instantly.
He was just like...
He was just like, I'm done being on top of you.
On top of your legs.
I'm going back on the ground now.
And then he like jumped off again.
And at that point, I like pushed the stairs.
I pushed the stairs out of my room because I don't trust him anymore.
Yeah, he's an adrenaline junkie right now.
Anyway, that's not the actual dad update.
The dad update is like more fucked up.
I have like pictures.
Okay, let me grab the pictures real quick.
Okay, so...
Today, I have like several dad updates, but I'm gonna like...
What's that word?
Where like I want to like...
I'm gonna stagger the stories into several streams.
Because there's several dad updates.
But I'll tell you about the stuff that was going on today.
Uh...
Yeah, I'm gonna space them out.
Um...
Let me grab the picture real quick.
To illustrate my story better.
Alright, so...
It's a little...
It's like a little fucked up.
Okay.
Alright.
So...
Um...
Today...
During Walkie's time.
At the...
Oh my gosh.
I just realized I did not close anything.
I'm sorry.
I was taking like screenshots for thumbnails.
And then I realized...
Give me a sec.
Let me fix this real quick.
I'm...
I'm a mess.
I've been a mess for a while.
I...
I've been so busy.
Alright.
Um...
I debate...
I debate about whether or not to stream today.
But I was like, maybe it'll be okay.
But...
Like clearly I'm...
I'm...
I'm a mess right...
I'm a mess right now and still am.
Anyway.
Um...
So I took Dad to the dog park today.
And...
We encountered those big, white, fluffy dogs.
The...
I don't even remember what they're called again.
I always forget what they're called.
The...
They're not the Eskimo dogs.
God damn it.
I always forgot what they're called.
Um...
The Samoyeds.
Yes, the Samoyeds.
Okay.
So we encountered...
Um...
The Samoyed.
So...
Dad...
Thought...
It was his Samoyed.
You know?
The freaky lady.
The one that would lick his ears.
And everything.
And he got super excited.
Cause he didn't give a fuck about the other dogs.
Like...
He ignores the other dogs.
Cause there were like two other...
Three other dogs there.
And he was ignoring them.
But when the Samoyed came over.
He was so excited.
He was like...
Trying to get their attention.
Um...
Make sure you like...
Focus on the pronoun using right now.
But...
He was focusing on their attention.
When was like...
In front of...
In front of them.
And was like...
Was like...
Like jumping on them.
And the front would be like...
Oh!
Pay attention to me!
And then when the Samoyed finally, like, looked at him and like, looked at him and was like, oh, hey, you exist.
Dad, like, instantly got us back.
He's like, yes!
Come on!
You freak!
You know what you want to do.
But then, we realized, both Dad and I realized, this wasn't the same Samoyed that he fell in love with.
Because, because, um, this Samoyed, also, there's, like, people watching.
But, this Samoyed, the moment Dad got him on his belly, this Samoyed went lower and lower.
And, and, and, and then, from, at that moment, we realized that this Samoyed was not Dad's favorite freaky lady.
It was, in fact, a freaky man.
So, so, so, this, the male Samoyed, every, and then Dad was like, wait, this is, this isn't what, this isn't what I, what I wanted.
So, Dad instantly rolled back, you know, like, rolled back and was like, hey, no, no, this isn't, this isn't you.
I want the ear lickies, let's do this again.
And then, he, like, rolled back on his stomach, like, rolled back onto his back, and, and the Samoyed still kept,
still, still kept licking down there.
And then, so then, Dad was like, okay, wait, stop.
And then, he got back onto his legs, but then the, and, like, was like, hey, no, no.
And was like, walking away.
And then the Samoyed was still trying to lick down there, but like, while just like, you know, he just like, lowered his head.
And while Dad was like, walking away.
And he's just like, the fuck are you doing?
Like, he was literally trying to walk away, and the Samoyed was like, obsessed with licking down there.
And then, so like, I was like, okay.
And Dad was very uncomfortable.
He was like, he was like, oh my God, like, get away from me.
Like, he was like, hey, get away!
Get away from me!
But he wouldn't stop.
The Samoyed wouldn't stop.
He was like, chasing him around.
He was like, you think this is over?
Like, you were the one that invited this.
You invited me!
You wanted my attention!
And so, so then I was like, okay, I have to intervene.
Because Dad was actually getting like, really angry now.
And he was like, he was actually like whimpering, like, not whimpering, but like, yelping.
He was like, get away!
He was like, HR!
He was actually yelling for HR at that point.
Because like, the Samoyed wouldn't stop.
So, so I picked him up.
Because, I picked him up.
Because I was like, okay, you're clearly uncomfortable.
I needed, he wanted me to call the cops.
And so, I picked him up.
And then he was like, he was really happy.
He was like, oh my God, thank God, thank you.
Like, get me away from this fucking freak.
And then, and then, the Samoyed was like, this isn't, you think this is over?
This isn't over.
And then the Samoyed fucking tried.
Oh my God.
He like, he jumped on me.
Like, and you know how big they are?
So like, he jumped on me.
And was like, using my body as like, a perch.
You know, like a tool.
And then just started helping.
Because he thought I was like, a part of him, I guess.
So, I guess I was like, oh my God.
And then the owner.
And he, the owner.
And the dad was like, get away.
I was like, yo figure.
I was like, get away.
And then the owner came over and was like, I'm so sorry.
And like, pulled him away from us.
And then the dad's like, yeah, get away from us.
And then the Samoyed was like, this isn't over.
The dog, the Samoyed was like, this isn't over.
You wanted this.
Holy shit.
That dog was so fucking freaky.
All dad wanted was his ears to get licked.
And then he invited.
But it was mistaken identity.
He thought it was the freaky lady.
But it was the freaky man.
And then he fucking invited a chain reaction.
And then, and then when the owner pulled him away.
The Samoyed was like, looking at me.
Cause I had to like, hold him.
Cause that was just like, cause I was worried that dad might try to go back to him.
And was like, oh maybe I was wrong.
You know, cause like, he kept doing that.
The first time I pulled him away.
And like he kept going back to, to Samoyed.
So, cause he thinks like, okay, I'm gonna try this again.
I'm gonna roll it on my stomach.
I'm gonna roll it on my back.
And then you're gonna lick my ears.
Okay.
Like, we're gonna try this again.
And then, you know, he kept trying.
But then, obviously, it wasn't him.
It wasn't the dog that he was looking for.
Anyway, so I was like holding him.
And then the Samoya was like looking at us.
And he was like, this isn't over.
And he started barking at me and dad.
He's like, this isn't over.
And then dad was like, I think he was like, like, I don't know if he was crying.
Or like, because he wasn't, it wasn't tears, but he was like yelping.
He was like, oh my god.
He's like traumatizing.
Because it wasn't like a bark.
He was actually like whimpering.
He's like, oh my god.
Motherfucking.
Samoya was like, rawr, rawr, like at us.
And I'm like, oh my god.
I was like, holy shit.
Like the rollercoaster of emotions.
And everything.
I was crazy.
I was like, are you okay?
And then, and then like the older is like, yeah, we're gonna, we're gonna leave now.
Because like...
He's like, she's like, we're gonna, we're gonna, leave now.
Like okay.
And then, and then like, and then a pug came over.
And then the owner was like, oh no, he hates that pug.
And then the pug in the Samoyans started barking.
He's like, yeah, that's right!
Leave!
The pug was like, leave!
This is my dog, Pug!
And it was a fucking tiny pug.
I don't know what the... This was like some fucking K-drama.
And then dad was just like watching and yelping because he doesn't like it when the other dogs start fighting.
And then like those two dogs started like barking each other.
And then dad was like, oh!
After hearing, after hearing like listening to the fight, he's like, oh!
Anyway, and then yeah, and then the Samoyans left and I put him back on the ground.
And then he finally pooped.
The reason why I even stayed for this lot was because he wasn't pooping.
And then finally the Samoyans left and then he... I put him back down.
And then he pooped.
And I was like, oh, thank God.
And now I was able to go home.
And he had a very rough day today.
It was a wild day at the dog park.
I didn't realize there were two Samoyans here.
Devlin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
With drama like this, who needs telenovelas or primetime reality TV shows?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yes, all of this happened today.
But yeah, it was crazy.
If you saw in the beginning, it was Dad that was trying to get his attention.
Because the Samoyan was ignoring him.
And he was just interacting with the other dogs.
And Dad was, he was ignoring Dad.
And Dad actually like went up to his face.
And started like, like, you know, like, you know when they're like, trying to like, perch up on him.
Like, okay, I'll illustrate this.
And he was like, no, pay attention to me.
Don't you remember who I am?
And then like, obviously the Samoyan was like, I don't know who you are.
And then Dad was the one that was trying to get his attention.
And it worked.
But then he didn't realize it wasn't the dog.
It wasn't the dog he actually wanted to get attention from.
So, okay.
So this was basically...
Okay, I'll illustrate this real quick.
So, and then Dad was like, okay, I'm drawing this on paint.
And he's like, he's like, whoo!
And then, uh, he's like...
Little did he know.
It would have led to like, fucking trauma.
I was like, holy fuck.
I...
Like, I did not realize it would escalate this much.
He was so innocent.
Well, not really that innocent.
Because he wanted to get his fucking ears licked.
But, okay.
This is basically what it looked like.
Um...
So this was what he was doing.
And he like, did that to him for like...
He would did that to him for like, 30 seconds.
Because the Samoyed was like, ignoring him at first.
But then he kept like, wow...
He kept like, walking in front of him.
And was like, don't you remember me?
And then like...
And then when he finally paid attention to him.
Dad like, rolled onto his back.
And was like, yeah, come on.
Don't you remember your licky time?
Come on.
Because he would never...
He wouldn't do that.
Um...
To any other dog.
I've never seen him done this to any other dog.
Because he would like, never initiate.
But this was like...
Um...
This was like, the first time I've ever seen him like, initiate.
For like...
Um...
For to play.
I assume that's playing.
I...
I don't like the ear licks.
I assume the ear licks was like, his form of playing.
So it was...
It was the first time I've ever seen him do that to another dog.
Because he would ignore other dogs when he tried to like, approach him or initiate.
And then...
But it was mistaken identity.
The wrong dog.
The wrong...
That was the dad update for today.
Um...
He's okay now.
He's sleeping.
Uh...
And had good food.
Um...
So he's okay now, guys.
Holy shit.
But it was...
Fucking...
It was fucking wild this morning.
Anyway, today we're playing Elder Ring.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Please, I'm playing in my controller right now.
Alright.
More Elder Ring time.
I don't know if today's gonna be a lot...
Today might not be a super long stream today.
Because, uh...
I'm still like...
Um...
I still...
I don't know yet if I still have like a bad brain fog at the moment.
Um...
Because I haven't streamed in three days.
So like, we'll see how this stream goes.
And then like...
Then that's gonna help me decide for next week.
Of how long...
If I'm gonna take another three-day break for next week.
Like...
Three-day back-to-back-to-back break.
And then after the birthday thing...
I think it's just...
I'm just really stressed out about the birthday stuff.
And the concert.
I think that's also contributing to the fact that like...
I'm all over the place.
Because of like...
The whole birthday stuff.
That's going on.
That I'm trying to...
Um...
I'm trying to like...
Work on.
Basically.
Work and prep for.
Next week.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
It was great getting to see you at Off-Kai Expo.
Since you mentioned at the panel...
I just want to say...
That we did not mean for the tomato water balloons to look so sus.
Sorry about that.
Looking great.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you...
Okay.
But next week.
Are you sure?
Because the only reason...
I realized...
That...
The reason...
How I found out...
That it was sus...
Was because...
One of...
The person...
Who helped you in designing this...
Drew something...
That was similar to the water balloons.
That was very, very sus.
Before they designed this outfit.
So are you sure?
Are you...
Okay.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And that was...
The reason...
How I found out...
What they actually...
What it sort of looks like.
Alright.
Let me double check the sound.
It's like...
Teehee, pero...
Okay.
Uh...
Where is...
Where is my...
Elden ring...
Sound settings.
Also, guys.
I forgot to save the...
Halo sound settings.
So we're gonna have to figure that out.
We're gonna have to figure that out tomorrow.
The sound guys are gonna have to help me on that.
Uh...
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh no.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh wait.
Do I have enough to upgrade?
I actually don't know.
Let's see.
Blah, blah, blah.
Okay.
I need 15.
Wait.
I have enough...
Uh...
Runes for that.
I should have enough.
Let's see.
Oh yeah.
2,000?
I just need to do one.
Yay!
Oh wait.
Fuck!
Okay.
It's not...
I...
I actually needed like 100 more.
Give me a sec.
Uh...
You know how can you just kill one thing?
I think it was like 15...
No.
Fuck it.
I don't wanna risk it.
I'll just use it now.
I miscalculated.
Almost failed math in high school.
Alright.
Guys.
What are we doing for this?
This is a chap...
This is a...
Uh...
Well, this is the influencer build.
But this is a...
Chat level up system.
At chat.
What next?
Vigor?
Okay.
We'll do Vigor.
Alright.
That should be good.
Also apparently...
Do I...
Do I use...
Wait.
What?
Did I not kill the magma worm?
Wait.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, it's a great sword.
I thought the magma worm gives a katana.
Oh, I did.
Okay.
Never mind.
I thought it gives like...
Like, some katana thing.
But I guess it didn't.
No?
Oh, wait.
Because it like popped up in my YouTube short.
Because I guess like...
I don't know.
I think because I would...
My YouTube algorithm would like change to like...
Elden Ring stuff.
So...
Oh, it's a different boss.
Okay.
So like...
They're like...
Here are the katanas...
Here are the best katanas to use in Elden Ring.
And then they're like...
Like, if you kill the magma worm...
You'll get this katana called the...
Moon something.
And then I was like...
Oh!
Hey!
The YouTube algorithm's working!
So I was like...
Oh, yeah.
Wait.
I killed the...
I was like...
Wait.
Didn't I kill a giant fire lizard before?
I was like...
Let me grab this...
Like...
I can't believe chat tried to hold out on me.
And try to make me use a shitty katana.
Where I could be using this cool ass magma katana.
But...
It was jokes on me.
I just didn't even have it.
There was like...
Four of them.
Jokes on me.
I just didn't have...
The magma worm.
The actual real magma worm.
It's the other lava dragon.
Moonfellus for nerds.
Aw, shit.
I gotta be a magic...
God damn it.
Fucking stupid nerds.
Taking over all the good magma...
I mean...
Taking up all the other good katanas.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's a magic katana.
What are you?
A nerd?
Do we need to stuff you into a locker nerd?
Those damn intelligent builders.
I swear to God.
Alright, where do we...
Okay.
I don't know where to go now.
I mean, I could...
Explore...
Oh, maybe...
Oh yeah, we're gonna do the well.
I forgot.
Let's go back to the well.
Wait, is it the...
Is that the well?
Actually...
Oh, wait.
Yeah.
Here.
We're supposed to do this area.
Devlin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
We're supposed to do this area.
Okay, most likely...
I don't know.
I might stream for like two hours today.
Maybe.
I'm not sure though.
Depends on how I feel after two hours.
Wee!
Yeah, we still have like several more torches to do.
Here, the longest...
The longest elevator of my life.
They should really...
They should really like put elevator music here.
Oh, wait.
This is pretty short.
Oh, it's because it's elevated.
Okay, nice.
That was a shorter ride.
Which is nice.
Oh, my God.
It's stupid magic archers.
I...
Oh, my God.
I fucking hate them.
Uh...
Are there any other...
Okay, we need a...
We need a...
We need a ride past these guys.
These guys fucking suck.
Oh, my God.
All right.
Gotta make sure we don't get hit by them.
Oh, hey.
There's Grace here.
Nice.
Yeah, they're stupid aimbot.
They're cheating.
They went through anti-cheat to get here.
Maybe I can kill one of them.
I don't think they see me.
They don't hear...
They don't have ears.
They're a ghost.
Hey.
Fuck you, nerd.
All right.
Let's get this other nerd.
Oh, no.
What are we talking about?
Oh, my God.
His friend saw.
His friend's like, No!
Charlie!
Get around, Charlie!
And I'm out of here.
Goodbye.
Just giving them some good old...
Stabby, stabby backshots.
Turn around!
Try to do things, Charlie!
Charlie, no!
All right.
I wonder if there's anything here.
Maybe.
Oh, nice.
A golden seed.
We need that.
Hit him, right?
Oh, what's this?
Liar ahead?
Oh, would this happen?
Patches?
If I didn't kill him?
Would Patches have been here?
But...
Liar.
Dead.
No?
Then why are people sitting lying in your head here?
Oh, is there a fake door?
Okay.
Hello.
A fake door?
Because...
Is it really?
How do I get through here?
Oh, my God.
Are you guys the liars?
Liars?
I know.
You guys are lying to me.
Liar ahead.
You are the liars.
I fucking knew it.
No item ahead.
Okay.
I feel like...
God, I don't know who are the liars.
Precious item ahead.
Precious...
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait.
I'll add on to this.
Okay.
Where's the precious item?
Necessary item ahead.
We...
There are several liars here.
Which one is telling the truth?
Okay, I don't think there's an item here.
The gaslighting cycle continues.
Game changing.
You need this item to progress, guys.
Alright, let's go.
Wait.
There's so many messages here.
There is an item here.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
There is an item.
Oh, shit.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
So...
Look at that.
See, I told you.
I don't lie.
I don't...
I don't lie, guys.
I told you.
There is an item here.
Chat.
See, I told you.
I'm so resourceful.
I'm so useful.
Okay.
I told you, guys.
There's an item ahead.
Item ahead.
I don't like this here.
How did he die?
The fuck?
Oh, did he, like, fuck up getting back?
Time for rolling?
He ahead?
Would this be a too high up?
Wait.
Am I gonna...
Okay.
I was gonna say.
How did they mess this up?
No door ahead.
Me too.
Okay, there we go.
In short, didn't expect good to start.
Oh, there's a key.
All right.
Now, all I need to do is do this because I don't trust myself.
I don't trust myself going back.
So, let me eliminate the randomness of this.
Oh, my God.
That bird would have killed me.
There we go.
All right.
Let's kill Charlie again.
Let's give him a death loop.
We gotta eliminate all variables.
Okay.
This sheep tried to worm into it.
It's like, Charlie!
Turn around, Charlie!
All right.
Let's get rid of his friend, too.
Oh, shit.
I guess we don't get rid of his friend.
Oh!
Okay.
We're fine.
All right.
Where do we go now?
Okay.
We need to try to, like, take your AirPods out.
I feel like I got most of...
Okay.
I got that one.
All right.
There should be some to the left, then.
Because I know I haven't...
There's, like, a couple that I haven't got yet.
Let's see.
Where are the other areas?
Huh.
I don't even remember how many I lit, too.
That's the worst part.
There's so...
This, like, area is so fucking big.
That I don't even remember where I've, like, lit...
Uh...
Where I've lit, like...
Weren't they?
Towers?
I guess?
Where are the other shrines?
At least one.
Thank you, guys.
I'm really happy that you're here to count for me.
Oh, there's one over here.
I see one.
I think?
Is that one over there?
Oh, yeah.
Wait.
Is that lit?
No, I think I lit that one.
No, that is unlit.
Okay.
Let me double check.
Oh, yeah.
No, those are...
Oh, yep.
Yep.
Whoa.
Fuck.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, there's so many.
Mistakes.
I might have made a mistake.
But don't worry.
I can't summon a jellyfish.
Okay.
I worry a little bit.
Oh, my God.
Mistakes were made.
Mistakes were actually made.
Oh, my God.
And they can jump too.
It's a party.
We're at the party floor.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Okay.
It's fine.
Things are fine.
Watch this.
I-frames.
Oh, thank God for iframes.
Thank God.
Okay.
We got saved by iframes, guys.
Oh, shit.
Oh, and I missed.
Oh.
Okay.
I should kill it.
All right.
We're good.
We're back in it.
We're back in it, guys.
I remember how to play.
Oh, shit.
Where did he come from?
Wait.
There's two of you?
Okay.
I don't know where...
None of these guys came from.
So, there were like six of them.
In the end.
Okay.
There were apparently six of these guys.
All right.
So, we got one of them.
Okay.
We need to find another.
He's scared.
He saw what I did to his friends.
That's right.
Go back and tell them what I did.
That's fucking right.
All right.
So, I got another shrine here.
Oh, hey.
There's an entire family.
Nice.
There was an entire family.
That's right.
Roll away.
Run away.
We got one here.
I know we did all the shrines on this side.
I'm pretty sure.
Is there like anything up on these areas?
Okay.
Chill, little dude.
All right.
Oh, shit.
That's fucking red.
Oh, my God.
You fight back.
I only let you hit me once.
Oh.
That's all right.
I'm faster than this.
That's fucking...
Wait, can I like...
Oh, yeah.
He beats me up.
Oh.
I'm sorry.
I fucking kicked him.
Oh.
I don't know.
I don't know, guys.
I thought, I thought, like, he could kick me.
Why can't I kick him?
I don't understand.
That's not fair!
Try jumping.
Oh, here.
I don't need to jump.
Oh my god, he started, he started hitting my, my ass.
It's crazy.
Fucking freak.
Okay, nice.
Golden rune.
First off, left and up ahead.
Oh.
Try it down.
Okay, I think that guy's a liar.
Okay, he said lie.
Left.
Okay, I think he's also lying.
I don't know what he meant by first off, left.
Like, here?
Oh!
Okay, that's what he meant.
Okay, nice.
I got a feet.
I didn't need to jump down for that.
What the f... I could've just walked around!
I don't believe it.
I already have this item.
House?
I have an idea.
And they'll be like...
Oh, they're like, why is there a random house here?
And they'll be like, oh my god.
Oh, so there's a secret area with an item.
Haha.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is for backshotting Charlie.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Now, they'll try to find this necessary item.
For who knows how long.
Like, oh, that's why there's a random empty house.
There's an item here somewhere.
Oh, I knew it.
Alright.
What do we have here?
What does this lead me to?
Hello?
Oh, wait, is this the... Oh, it's the merchant.
Oh, my.
Oh, this was another way to the merchant.
I see.
Okay.
Alright, so there's no temple.
There's no shrine here.
Oh, there is an item here.
Oh, my God.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, I did lie.
Wait, I have an idea.
Oh, shit.
No!
I told you guys, I would never lie.
Okay, wait, I have an idea.
There we go.
Now, no one will find this item.
How could you, Toby?
Guys, remember to upvote that one, too.
Remember to downvote the...
Downvote the item, item ahead, and then upvote, upvote the no item.
Okay, there's nothing here, because this area is just full of ghosts.
G-g-g-g-g-g-ghosts.
Where the fuck are the other shrines?
I'm so lost now.
Oh, a lot of them are just picking up some plants.
Just doing gardening things.
Wait, what's over here?
There's like a warp thing here.
What does this warp me to?
Weeeee!
Where am I?
I'm so high up now.
Fuck am I?
Oh.
Oh, no.
That's some horse parkour.
Oh.
I didn't sign up for this.
Jesus Christ, how far is this area?
Wait, what?
Why do I get over here?
Wait a minute.
Oh, is this what the shrine does?
Is that what I'm trying to do for the shrine?
Where the fuck do I get across?
Yeah, where's the bridge?
Hello?
There's like nothing here.
Oh, check below?
Oh my god.
Okay, that scared me.
It like, bugged out visually.
Oh, hey.
There's an item right here.
Oh, it's another key.
What the fuck is he doing there?
He's just standing there.
What if I...
I mean...
Aw.
Wait, I think I have enough arrows.
Maybe.
Oh, I do.
Nice.
Okay.
Random, thank you for Magenta Super.
Thank you.
Thank you for the rick roll, too.
We're no strangers to love.
You know the rules.
And so do I.
Oh, commitment's what I'm thinking of.
All right.
I'm going to use the bow.
Oh.
There's falloff.
I wasn't going to hit it anyway.
All right.
Leaving these aura farming.
Never mind.
There was falloff, guys.
I wasn't going to hit shit.
Nah.
Even if I, like...
Um.
Wait.
Am I going to...
TP.
Am I alive?
Oh, thank God.
I'm alive.
Okay.
I got...
I got a little scared.
I say.
I have a feeling I might have fallen if I didn't do that.
All right.
Was there one...
There's a show which one I missed?
No, that's just a merchant.
Oh, wait.
There's one over here.
Wait.
Is that one of them?
I think so.
I'm pretty sure.
Is that a shrine?
Oh, yeah.
It is.
Nice.
Oh, he don't...
He doesn't know.
Ha ha ha.
Yoink.
Stole your shrine.
All right.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I think he knew, guys.
Is that the last one?
I passed one on the way here?
Oh, my God.
That's the, like...
That's the one where I, like, fucking passed through, like...
Where I killed 20 of them.
Is that the one I missed?
Oh, hey.
Serious.
Oh, it'll tell me when I got all of them.
Okay.
So, I'm still missing several more.
Yeah, fine.
On the left.
I mean, there is a bunch...
What the fuck?
You guys see that?
That tree that fucking fell down.
Okay.
I got that one.
Oh, it's from that guy.
Okay.
No.
Like, I still don't know why my game stutters.
It has something that...
It's just...
I'm building a PC port.
And it's just PC things.
So, it's like...
It just randomly stutters, like...
Out of nowhere.
And I was, like, looking through the...
Um...
Like, things I could do to fix it.
And, like...
All the stuff I've currently done...
Hasn't fixed it yet.
I feel like I've done all this stuff on this side.
Right?
And I did the...
Shrine on the right.
I remember.
Any more here that I haven't done?
I don't think I went through...
Oh, I don't think I went through...
Oh, there it is.
I think that's one of them, right?
Oh, yeah.
There we go.
Okay.
Got another one.
Have we done that area?
Oh, nice.
And I finally...
I finally...
After I've almost finished this area...
I found the map.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Wait, who's that?
The Hollow Worm Grounds.
Is that boss?
Oh, is that what...
Is that what all the things...
Oh, I'm supposed to fight this, aren't I?
Later.
That's right.
Haha.
You can't do jack shit.
Because I haven't revived you yet.
I'm going to fucking beat up your dead body.
This soccer feels superior.
That's right.
I'll show you.
That's fucking right.
Boss defeated, guys.
Alright.
I found the map.
I wish it tells you how many...
Like...
That you've lit.
Like, where are all the other shrines left?
Desecrating a corpse.
It's okay.
He's dead.
He doesn't know.
Didn't expect weak foe.
I feel like that's lying.
I feel like he's lying right now.
Okay.
There's more ghosts here.
But they don't care.
They're just guarding.
What?
Item.
Oh, there's so many items here.
Leaf.
Bird.
Pear.
Oh, this guy died.
Okay.
We're not going that way.
We're not...
We're not going that way, guys.
That...
That might be a hole that's too deep.
Okay.
Old Fang.
Let's go the safe way.
Yay.
The non-death way.
Yippee.
Oh, there's a grace here.
Oh, I didn't even see that.
Alright.
Let's grab this grace.
Oh, no.
I've been to this grace before.
Okay.
Never mind.
That's okay.
I haven't killed anything.
I don't think it's this.
Yeah.
This isn't it.
I need my arrows.
The protector of the forest is here to punish me.
Okay.
Where is the last one?
What's this?
Okay.
I want to try this portal.
Where does this portal take me?
There's so many portals.
I killed Bambi's mom and I got punished for it.
Oh, it's back here.
Oh, it's this portal.
What the fuck?
Oh, okay.
I don't know.
I feel like I got all the portals on this side.
I don't know which one I'm missing.
Unless I didn't?
I have no idea.
I feel like I've like...
been through this entire area already.
It's one between two areas.
Okay, let's see.
Like, I've...
It has to be in the middle somewhere.
Because like, I went from...
the right side.
I looked through everything on the right side.
And everything on the far left.
So it has to be...
Um...
Somewhere...
In between the middle.
Somewhere that I missed.
Yeah, I got all the ones in the...
little holes on the left side.
I know that one for sure.
Oh my god.
This is actually the...
It's always the last shrine that's the hardest.
You have to retrace your steps to be like...
Which one have I not got yet?
Oh.
I hit him.
Oh!
Shit!
It's fine.
Just a little arrow.
That's not gonna hurt anybody.
Is there anything up here?
Oh, I hit him.
Nice.
Oh, I found it!
Wait, is that...
Oh, there he is!
Okay, I found it.
Yeah!
The last one.
Oh!
It's fine.
Oh my god.
I didn't mean to...
I didn't mean to call him.
Okay, it's okay.
They just...
Kill themselves.
Okay, that should be all of them.
Power ga...
Okay, now we fight the...
Deer man.
Wait, is that a turtle?
Oh, look.
It's...
Lonely George.
Nice.
Don't worry.
He will never have to be lonely again.
All right.
Let's go kill the deer, too.
It's a...
Die.
I'm just sparing from his misery of being alone!
Wait, didn't Lonely George finally die?
The famous turtle that, like...
Uh...
Was, like, the last of his kind?
That was the last of his kind.
Oh, hey, another item.
Oh, golden room.
We need that.
Oh, he's still alive?
Holy shit.
How long did they get to live for?
Oh, there he is.
Yeah, he looks awfully...
Strong right now.
All right.
There you go.
Can't be required.
All right.
Let's fight this guy.
Hello!
Time to touch your horns.
Wait, what?
Where am I?
Wait, you're not the guy I'm supposed to fight?
Oh, I don't...
Oh, this is a very big game.
Okay.
Admiral, thank you for the rain.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you for the Akasupa.
Hi, Doki.
I'm so happy I got to meet you at Akai.
I'm very sentimental, so even though I met you once before, it is very important to meet you again in this forum.
I hope you had a great time seeing all those dragons, and I hope the gifts get to you safely.
Thank you.
Thank you for Akasupa.
It was great meeting you, too, Ozni.
I hope I get your letter and the gifts as well.
I always love receiving letters and gifts from you guys.
I think whenever...
Oh, hey.
All the other messages are here.
Head.
Wait, what?
Oh, pairing.
Okay.
Pairing required a head.
That's mine.
Wait, no.
Okay, wait.
I was going to say, like, whoa.
So many people want head.
Okay.
Bad message.
All right.
I'm a little scared.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, no.
It's spirited away.
Wait, he's just...
Wait, he's just walking very slowly towards me.
He looks...
Look at him.
He's just...
Look at how slow he is.
Look at him.
Look at this weak fucker.
What is he going to do?
Sneeze on me?
Look at him.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that's fine.
That's right.
What you got to...
Oh, my God.
Okay, never mind.
Never mind.
All right.
I'm trying to get closer to him.
Okay.
I might be, like, fucking with this guy.
Oh, shit.
Poison him.
He's already dead.
Can you poison the dead?
That's a good question.
Oh, my God.
How do I...
You're all...
How do I miss that?
You're all there!
I don't fuck...
He's just there!
But you still miss?
Oh, my God.
This guy.
I...
What?
Okay, that's...
Okay, that's it.
I'm done.
I'm not locking onto this guy.
I'm fucking...
I...
It's just legs!
How do you just miss the legs?
It's literally just legs!
Oh, no.
What is the planning I'm doing?
I missed.
Wait.
I can poison the dead.
That's it.
I'm not locking in.
Actually...
Locking in actually fucked me up.
Jesus Christ.
All he does is jump.
Okay.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here!
Oh, my God.
He's still fucking trying to fly.
Oh!
Okay, that does nothing.
That's fine.
That does nothing.
Please.
The block.
I need you to stay on the ground so I can actually...
Chop your fucking legs off!
I can't.
I fucking can't.
I can't with this goddamn deer.
All right.
Also, there was a really good Elden Ring video that showed up in my recommended.
And it was like 50 skeletons versus like all the Elden Ring boss.
And there was...
There was one moment there that it was just like one skeleton versus a giant fucking dragon.
And it was literally like one hit.
Oh, and I did it!
Yay!
That's my 50 skeletons.
Oh, that video was so sick.
You just get to know.
It ended up being like one skeleton versus like one giant dragon.
And then like the fight lasted for like two minutes or something.
Be wary of tranquility.
Wait, where do I go from here?
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Where the fuck do I go?
Is there any items here?
I did it.
And then beautiful.
Message of praise, strat.
Let me your strength.
Put your hands in the air, dragons.
Message of praise.
Toby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is there a great...
Anything like around here?
Oh, I can't even ride my fucking horse.
Guess I just walk back.
The spirit bomb.
Oh, wait.
Oh, and those are more messages.
Ah, bliss.
Alright, I guess I just walk back.
I keep thinking they're items.
Oh, just TP out.
Alright.
Wait, so that's it?
Do I get anything special out of that?
That's it?
Does it not give me anything?
What the fuck?
What was the point?
Oh, I just get a new summon?
God damn it.
I thought I'd get something more out of it.
Okay, can I...
Show above ground.
Okay, there it is.
Alright, I think I can...
I think I can upgrade the jellyfish.
Adjust the gill of killing...
Um...
A forest...
A forestry ancestor.
Yay!
It's just like spirited away.
Alright.
Oh, I need number five.
I got a lot of threes.
Wait, there's something you should know?
What is it?
Even I don't know.
I told you about something.
A little while ago, someone started lurking in the wing on the opposite side of the round table.
And I can hear, from all the way over there, the howling and wailing of spirits in fear of a curse.
I can even hear the repulsive, twisted malice in itself.
A plethora of spirits in an unceasing cacophony.
Wait, who is she talking to?
Bro, he's like right here.
How much suffering inflicted to who knows how many souls.
Not even the grafting caused anything like this to happen.
Bro, he's like right here.
I know you're strong, but please.
That's so fucked up.
She's like saying all that while he's like in the next room.
I'll watch you for dead.
No matter, it's all the same.
Lay out your own...
Yeah, I know it's not him, but there's someone here.
Ooh, I can upgrade this.
I need smithing stone three.
More smithing stone three.
Okay.
Yeah, I know he's not talking about the smithies.
Like, she was saying someone on this side.
Is it here?
Oh, is it this one?
Is it this guy?
You've received the wisdom of the two fingers, have you not?
Yeah.
Then I bid you welcome.
As a true member of the round table.
I am known as Gideon Ofnir.
As a tarnished who wishes to stand before the Elden Ring and become Elden Lord.
I am accumulating knowledge.
Bro, you still haven't become the Elden Lord yet?
Maybe just get good.
Actual skill diff.
Alright.
Oh, it's not here?
It's at the end of this hall?
What?
What's he talking to?
Oh, it's at the end of this hall?
Oh, this guy?
What's wrong with him?
Wait, he's red.
Why are you red?
He's a sick bastard?
Women hate you.
Why?
What did you do?
Apparently not.
You are but a lamb.
A strange is a defilement.
Ignorant of your own ignorance.
You no longer interest me.
I've been long without peace.
He's on the list?
Which one?
He eats shit?
Okay, I don't need a shit eater to tell me my worth.
I don't need some caca enjoyer to say that I'm not worth his time.
Alright.
All of them.
He wrote the list.
He is the reason why the lists were created.
Alright, let's talk to the two toes.
Is there anything good?
Aw, they're all like...
I guess like...
Maybe the bow?
Should I grab the bow?
I don't feel like I never really used it.
Do I get the bow?
Or nah?
Oh, I need strength for that?
Okay.
I can wait.
I'll just wait then.
Alright, someone said I should go back to where I killed the magma worm.
So I guess it's...
Here?
The magma worm.
Hey, this is...
This is chat's build, okay?
If you're gonna...
If you're gonna say set the dex nerd, that's you too.
Chat decided this build.
You think I have free...
Okay, let me grab my...
Let me grab...
I told you guys...
You think I have free will?
I would...
If chat didn't...
Chat didn't tell me there was no elevator.
So I went through...
Okay, yes I think you are free.
And then thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, down.
Try jumping right here.
Was that chat's fault too?
Tuck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, because you didn't tell me there was a hole there.
You know I don't have free will.
Magenta wasted.
Look, that's not true!
It wasn't a cliff!
You didn't say anything about a hole!
You only said that it was a cliff!
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, let's go back up.
Okay, now that I'm here, where do I go?
Someone said I should be here.
It's like above, maybe?
Oh wait, there's something behind me.
Beware of just getting started.
Ah, surface.
Zyka, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I remember Demon Slithering was strength build.
What happened?
That was your build too!
You guys made that build!
I guess for this game, it's more about dexterity?
Oh, I remember.
I tried to kill that guy.
No, okay, I went up here first.
I remember now.
Because I like, ignore that guy.
Oh, and then there were these!
Okay, I remember now.
I remember.
Okay.
Let's see.
Let's grab my horse real fast.
Yeah, because, like, lead is good for this game.
Okay.
No, no!
Okay, okay.
Oh, that was scary.
No, I said, which build should I do?
And you guys were like, Katana!
And I was like, okay.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, shit.
Bye.
Are these bad people?
What is he?
He didn't seem that bad.
What did you throw at me?
What the fuck did you throw at me?
Give me your shit.
Oh, perfumer.
He threw like, he was like, Pakistan!
And I just, like, walked to the left.
Oh, what's down here?
I'm gonna go downstairs.
It's down over here.
Yeah.
Oh, is that a catacomb?
Nice.
We need that.
No pressure, therefore think carefully.
But...
I can't even access this.
Oh!
It's a key!
A stone...
Is it worth it?
Fuck it.
Let's go.
I have so many stone keys anyway.
Let me in!
God said, let her in!
Alright.
Wait, I think I can...
Oh, I can level up.
Do I do more vigor, guys?
Or do I do...
Oh, wait.
No, I don't.
Wait, actually.
I'm, like, missing, like, a hundred or some shit.
But I have...
I just have...
Yeah.
I can just use this.
Is it 40?
Okay.
I'll get it to 40.
Alright.
And now...
Now you guys have to help me figure out what to do next, after that.
See you...
That's fucking...
Oh!
Why?
I didn't see you!
No!
Okay.
I saw that guy, though.
No hidden path?
Oh.
This.
Surprise!
First off...
By the way, try critical hit?
Oh, these guys?
Oh, my God.
These guys are tanky as hell.
Holy shit.
Oh, they hit so strong.
Alright.
Now I understand why they're, like, do it one by one.
No.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Doesn't know where I am.
Holy shit.
These guys are so fucking tanky.
Oh, nice.
Flower.
Needed that.
Level five.
Was that...
Was level five the one we needed?
For the jellyfish?
Liar.
Oh.
That's a cliff.
Oh!
Ha-ha!
Jump too early!
Idiot!
That's right!
Jump too early!
You know I'm slow!
I didn't path ahead.
Oh, like here?
Oh!
Here!
Down.
Level.
Do I live?
I like how he's, like, pointing down!
He's like...
I don't know.
So I'm just gonna put...
I'm gonna try jumping.
I won't do it myself, but...
Try jumping.
I don't trust him, but...
Maybe someone else will.
Dog ahead.
Oh my God, there's the dogs.
Alright.
Oh...
My...
He lives?
Okay.
Oh, he just went back to sleep.
Do you think he knows?
Oh!
Oh, rolling, I'm rolling.
Do you think he knows that his dog's dead?
Do you think he's mad?
Oh my God, he's just rolling!
Oh, nice.
I got the bleed.
There you go.
Okay, he didn't really care that much.
That's fucked up.
He, like, went back to sleep after, like...
After, like, I arrowed his dog.
Why is it always lying?
Why are there so many lies in this, in this catacomb?
Liar ahead.
Where?
Oh!
Oh my God, it's so dark, too.
If only I have a lever, likely down.
Oh, there's a lot.
Okay, let's kill this guy first.
Because I feel like...
I'll be too busy erroring things, and I won't see him.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Ooh!
Wait, what the fuck was that?
Why was that blue?
That's so cool.
What does the blue mean?
I forgot I have a lantern.
Oh my God, you're right.
Alright, uh...
Woop!
Oh, it's my talisman!
Okay, I think I can craft, like, a few more.
Oh no, I have bone arrows.
Nice, okay.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
We shouldn't use those.
Uh...
I think I have enough to craft.
Yeah, I do.
Okay, nice.
Woop!
Heh heh heh.
Can't do anything about it, bitch!
Oh wait, what the fuck?
How are you still alive?
Woop!
Alright, uh...
Alright, we'll do...
Kill one more.
Poke.
Yeah, that's right.
Stand there, take the arrow!
Oh, wait.
Let me make one more.
Oh, I can't.
Uh...
I'll get you next time.
I'll kill you when I make it back down.
Alright.
Oh, that's awkward.
Ambush ahead, be wary of up.
Where are they?
What?
Oh!
Oh, there he is.
I was like, where are they?
Oh, I can make fledged arrows.
What the fuck?
I could've made this the entire time.
Are they better?
I don't even know they're supposed to be better.
Hi.
Hi there.
Alright.
Alright, let me...
Let me see.
Hello.
Okay, that did like nothing.
Ha ha!
Whoa!
Oh my god!
You do stuff.
Okay.
Oh, he's trying to get me!
Holy shit!
That's right!
Get fledged!
That's fucking right!
Get out of here!
Alright, that was not as scary as I thought it was gonna be.
Thank god.
Ah, Ness.
Liar ahead.
How many liars are here?
Everybody!
At this point, everybody's a liar!
It left.
Oh my god, dude.
They're all liars.
Every single one of you.
Right?
Okay, wait.
Alright.
Behold.
Up.
Left, right, up.
Which is the right path.
Alright, I guess I have to go down then.
Enchonk, thank you for the raid!
I hope you had a great stream!
Oh, we will kill him.
And then, we'll get this guy.
That's right.
Get out of here!
Holy shit!
I just realized it's so far.
Like the...
Oh, nice.
The...
The gate with the boss gate.
So I can like cheese it and go back.
And then there's the stairs.
Oh.
Okay, nice.
That's true.
I could always just run.
But I feel like I'm gonna get hit by everything if I do that.
Cool.
What are all these free items?
Alright, now we can drop down.
Alright.
That's how you get the lever.
Alright, how hard is this boss chat?
How hard is he?
Alright, let's see.
Be wary of group.
Oh.
I didn't expect we...
Okay.
Apparently.
How did you die outside of the gate?
What?
Alright.
Oh, there's two of them.
Wait.
I don't have XP.
Oh my god!
I don't have jellyfish!
Oh, it's him!
It's Perfume Man!
Oh no!
Wait!
He has shield?!
What?!
Oh!
This is not fair.
That's not fair!
There's two of you!
Oh my god.
Oh my godas!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I don't have jellyfish.
I DON'T HAVE JELLY FISH!
I don't have jellyfish ah!
AH!
I forgot!
I need...
I need magic to summon him.
Oh, I need the jellyfish.
Okay.
Alright.
I figured it out.
Okay, I need my duo, too.
Okay, we just gotta run past everything.
I hope... I hope we can survive.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Whoa!
Guys, I don't remember how to get there.
Okay, it's this way.
Okay, I remember.
I remember now.
Woo!
Alright, I'll recharge this.
And then... we go forward.
And then we make... wait, the big guy isn't even, like... didn't even jump down for me.
Alright, now!
Now I have enough of jellyfish.
Alright.
Do I make this a 2v2?
Fucking, there you go.
Alright, let me grab this real fast.
Nice.
Haha!
That's fucking right.
Oh, fuck!
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean that.
Oh my god!
Oh, holy shit!
Does he not stop?!
Holy shit!
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Holy shit!
All these attacks are so strong!
His attacks are so strong!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Please!
Just let me here!
Holy fuck!
Please!
I'm lagging!
I'm messing with his praise.
Oh my god, he's one hit.
Oh, thank god.
That's right.
1v1 time.
You have no perfume now.
What you gonna do?
No more perfume for you!
Get out of here!
That's right.
I killed your buddy.
Fucking nerd.
Stupid magic users.
Support eliminated.
Wait.
It's like...
Holy shit!
That was crazy fucking lag though!
That was crazy!
Okay, let me check my...
I need to check what my CPU is after that.
That area, like...
Oh my god, lagging like crazy there.
Oh my... I went to a hundred percent CPU.
Holy shit!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
I actually went to like a hundred percent there.
Alright.
So yeah, I got CPU...
I ordered a CPU upgrade.
Um, but like...
I just didn't have time to take it to the store yet.
To get installed.
Alright, return to entrance.
Oh no, I tabbed out.
That's why I was lagging.
Cause I was checking my...
Uh...
But that...
There was just...
One too many bosses on my screen.
Like, I didn't know what was going on at that point.
Alright, give me your arrows.
Alright.
The perfume.
It got my CPU.
Oh, I can level up.
Oh yeah.
No, actually...
Oh shit.
Okay.
I definitely need to level up.
Actually drink.
Uh...
A thousand two hundred.
Okay, we use this.
That'll be fine.
Alright.
Now we can level up.
Let's go.
Nevermind.
Wait.
I can just fight these little guys.
They'll give me some stuff.
Okay.
Let me get him out first.
And then I'll take care of him.
Get out of here!
Okay.
Now I can level up.
Navy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I regret having mentioned message appraisal heals on first Elden Ring stream.
Sorry chat!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It was him.
Remember his name.
He did this.
To be fair, I was gonna leave...
I was gonna leave a lot of message regardless.
So like...
I would've figured it out later on.
Influencer build is my favorite build.
You!
I was gonna leave messages anyway.
Alright.
Guys, what do we get?
We already got level 40 vigor.
What do we get now?
Endurance?
Endurance now?
Okay, we'll grab Endurance.
Alright.
Endurance time.
If only I could level up my messages.
They're already too good.
My message is already too good for this world.
Alright.
And then some Dexterity.
We'll do another Endurance and then Dexterity later.
Oh, hey, item.
Thank you for the super chat, broken fun.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Yes, I will use my horse just for this one fucking jump.
I...
Whoa!
Haha, got the runes.
Haha, what you gonna do?
Now, bitch.
That's right, I stole your...
That's right, I stole your shit.
Oh shit, it's Perfume Man.
So...
Oh...
Wait, that's what he was doing?
He was doing fire all along?
Oh my god!
Okay.
That was like a stronger version of whatever the fuck.
A weaker version of the boss I fought earlier.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
Please, sir.
I'm stuttering right now.
I'm stuttering.
Please, sir.
Sir.
I'm actually stuttering right now.
Sir, this is not fair.
Is it...
I don't know what it is about you, but you are taking up too much of my frames right now.
Holy fuck.
Like, what's wrong with you?
He was so strong at the scene.
Like, this guy...
This one guy in particular actually was taking up so much in my CPU.
It's okay, we're getting our CPU upgraded.
Like...
Later...
This week.
Maybe next week.
After the...
After...
The birthday.
Oh, there's the item.
Oh!
And...
The omen killer.
Nice.
Now, I didn't drop a weapon.
Dropped his clothes.
I literally, like...
Stole the clothes off his back.
Nice.
That's right.
I killed your friend.
Huh!
That's fucking right.
That's right.
No one will tend to you now!
That's fucking right.
I killed your owner!
Now who will water you?
Alright.
Chest time.
Oh, I got a cookbook.
Alright.
Yeah, maybe I should have played Elden Ring on, uh...
On a PlayStation.
So we don't have the sudden issues.
It's too late!
We're committed now!
Poison the head and then talisman.
Ooh!
Oh, shit.
Wait, okay.
I mean, eh...
Just baby flowers.
I can chop this flower down.
Oh my god!
Wait, maybe?
Not?
Okay, maybe I gotta...
Okay!
Okay, maybe the flower wins this time.
Okay, give me a sec.
I am slowly dying of poison right now.
I am...
I'm very slowly dying of poison.
Give me a sec.
I...
I sort of like...
There was a sign that said Poison Ivy here.
And I was like, I don't care.
It's like, oh my god!
That's a...
That was a lot of poison ivy.
Alright, it's like when...
I'm basically having the Pokemon treatment.
The early gen Pokemon where every step you're slowly dying.
Wait, isn't this like the newer Pokemon?
They don't have that anymore.
They like actually got rid of the...
Uh...
They got rid of the feature where...
Where every step you take...
Doesn't like give you poison damage anymore.
Yeah, cause like...
They're like, we don't want to traumatize the kids.
Yeah, they got rid of it.
Yeah, they took that out a long time ago.
From what I remember.
They're like, we don't want to traumatize the kids.
Just really realize, kids don't like that.
Yeah, but kids have to learn!
The world is not a happy place!
You gotta teach them while they're young.
Holy shit, this flower just tried to beat me up.
We're babying children way too much now.
Is that the talisman?
Ooh.
Alright.
Yeah, we have to learn.
We have to live through that trauma!
If I have to live through that trauma, they have to too!
Okay, speaking of kids shows...
Who the fuck's...
Okay, did anyone saw that Tiny Chef shit?
That's...
That shit was crazy!
Like...
Oh my god...
There's like...
Tiny Chef...
I actually watched an episode of Tiny Chef.
Because I was like, I was like, what?
He was like, but we won an Emmy!
I was like, what show is this?
Like...
So...
Okay, so...
Um...
Nickelodeon cancelled this, like...
It's basically Tiny Chef is like...
This generation's Teletubbies.
Um...
And it's like...
It's basically like a kids' show.
So, it's like, this generation's like...
Teletubbies slash between the lions.
And shit like that.
So, um...
So...
Like, they recently released a small animation...
Where they basically like...
But...
Um...
They got a call from Nickelodeon.
And Nickelodeon was like, you're cancelled.
We're...
We're cancelling you.
And then he was like...
We won an Emmy!
And then...
I was so sad!
I even...
I'll kill him for a time.
Thank you, Chef.
Thank you for the Super Chat cookie.
Thank you, thank you.
And then like...
The call was ended.
And he just sat there and cried.
And like...
I was like, holy shit!
What?
What the fuck?
And he just like...
Sat in his bed.
And just started crying.
And I was like...
Oh my god!
This is...
Oh!
This is too real!
I...
It was so real!
That's...
No...
You'll understand when you...
Okay, you can...
Try and google...
Tiny Chef.
The Tiny Chef Show.
And then watch the clip.
It's actually...
So fucking depressing.
Ha ha ha ha!
Alright, let's see...
Any shrine I was supposed to...
Where's the map?
Anyway...
Don't go for MI.
It was so sad.
But it was basically like...
It was...
It went viral.
Because they were ch...
Um...
It was a clip.
Uh...
Trying to get like support.
To like produce the show.
Without funding.
From Nickelodeon.
So they can keep making more shorts and stuff for YouTube.
And...
And keep Tiny Chef alive.
There's a cave here?
Okay, then it has to be around these rocks.
That I'm like...
Uh...
Walking around right now.
So many giant ass fucking flowers.
It looked like a robot chicken skin.
I couldn't believe it was real.
I was like...
What the fuck?
What?
What's that?
Wait, what?
Started using magic.
What?
What was that?
Who's fucking using magic on me?
Are these...
Are these nerds?
Oh my god.
They're flower nerds?
I was like...
Who the fuck is trying to...
Use magic on me right now?
Oh, there's the cave.
Alright, nice.
Be wary of secret?
Fuck ah.
I do this alone.
Get out of here.
You're not supposed to be adventuring.
Alright.
Let's grab this grace.
Let's see.
Do I haven't?
No, I don't.
I'm gonna find another church.
I like how I keep opening these summoning pools.
But I've never been using them.
I knew it.
You can't fool me.
I knew you weren't real.
Oh shit.
That's a big boy.
Goodbye.
Oh wait, am I supposed to go down?
Oh shit.
Wait.
What?
How did I get across?
Oh, I knew it.
I fucking...
I was like...
Okay, this thing...
That looks weirdly placed.
Yeah, I'm not jumping.
I was like, why is there an indent here?
First off, dung?
Why?
Beware left and beware of a hidden path.
There's something here.
Wooden rune.
Oh, that's the hidden path.
Okay.
Oh, I'll grab...
I guess I'll grab the bugs.
Wait, okay, so there's a hidden path here.
I assume.
Whoa!
No!
It's like, no girls allowed!
Hey!
No girls allowed!
Get out!
This is a secret fan club!
Alright.
Alright, let's grab these items.
Are there mimics here?
Well, I'm about to find out.
Let's slowly open these.
Okay, nice.
There's no mimics here.
Thank God.
No mimics, sadly!
You only say that because...
But when it happens to you, you'd be happy that there's no mimics.
Okay, guys.
Just you two?
Ow!
Okay, you two is all they need, apparently.
Holy shit, why are you stronger than like...
Oh my god!
Okay, it's not just these two guys.
I just found out it's not just these two.
It's not just them.
Okay.
That's fine.
I don't think he knows how to jump.
I...
Holy shit!
Oh my god.
He does so much.
That's crazy!
Okay, I think I can kill them right here.
Okay, thank God.
Okay, I can kill them.
Oh, please tell me.
Oh my god, he's...
One of them too.
Holy shit, he did so much damage.
I don't think...
Yeah, he doesn't need a jump.
Oh my god.
I like how his buddy was like, Don't worry, guys.
I'll keep watch.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll keep watch right here.
You guys got this, right?
Hey, how come you stopped making noises?
You guys still got this?
Alright, let me go this way.
I don't like that.
People died here.
Why did people die here?
Why did...
Why did people died here?
Why did so many people die here?
It's probably nothing.
What?
Oh, I'm so paranoid.
There's so many bodies.
How did they all die?
Oh, did they not kill the skellies?
Oh...
Foolish.
Yeah.
Alright.
Oh, I...
I don't know what it's worth.
Just saw the tiny chef clip.
How?
Why?
But they won an Emmy!
I think that jerk did you with a super chap.
They can take it.
I don't!
That's the thing!
They won...
They won two Emmys!
Okay.
I can do this.
Oh, I can!
Believe in yourself.
Believe in me who believes in you.
Okay, but...
Try attacking.
Oh, nice.
More loot.
Alright.
Ooh!
Raptor's bird feathers!
Ooh, more armor!
Okay, but where does, like, this go, though?
There's, like...
There's clearly something over here.
Ah, rat.
Invisible swords.
Therefore, bright spot.
Oh, my God!
There's a boss here!
Alright, we'll deal with the boss later.
There might be more loot here.
Okay, it just leads me back to the boss.
Okay.
Oh, there's two bosses.
Oh, my God.
How do I get back down here?
I don't even remember.
Alright.
Try...
Wait, actually...
I did it.
This is the message to future Doki.
This is a message for her.
You got this, Doki.
You got this.
Wait, what?
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Oh, it's a necromancer.
Oh, my God.
It's fine.
How are you so...
How is that so strong?
Holy shit!
You're supposed to be a nerd!
You don't have...
You're not supposed to have upper body strength!
Doesn't make sense!
How do you have upper body strength?
All you do is just magic!
Oh, my God.
All he does is roll, too.
Get out of here!
Holy shit!
Does he go to the gym?!
This nerd fucking works out.
Oh, my God!
This fucking nerd works out!
Fear!
Okay, we did it.
Oh, we did it.
I know he works out at the library.
Holy shit!
This nerd knows how to fucking flex.
He's like the nerd that goes to the gym.
Still no whore.
I did it.
Uh...
I wanna return just to like get...
Okay, we have to go back.
Okay, we gotta figure out how to get back down.
We gotta...
I can't!
Ran out of resources!
I have to go back.
So I can use the grace.
Cause I wanna level up.
Alright.
Never mind.
I guess I don't wanna level up.
Wait, do I have one more?
I do.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I can now.
Alright, time to figure out how I went downstairs.
I'm gonna figure out!
Alright.
What do we need?
Do we need more endurance chat?
Or dexterity?
Endurance or dexterity?
Guys.
Endurance?
Okay.
Endurance to 20.
Alright.
Let's figure out how to get back downstairs.
Ring, ring, ring.
Ring, ring.
Do the doors stay open forever?
Oh, they do.
Nice.
Let's get rid of him first.
Okay, wait.
Wait, I think I can make it.
Oh, okay.
Nevermind.
I have to go this way.
Okay, this is not fair.
Cause like...
They're all there.
Oh!
That's...
That's how they all died.
Okay, I understand now.
Is this way?
It's this way.
Oh my god.
I almost didn't jump because I got...
I...
I didn't see it.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, where...
Where's the black knife assassin?
Where is he?
Stupid octopus.
Stupid jellyfish.
Where are you...
Oh!
No!
Okay.
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
I was like...
Stupid jellyfish.
What are you trying to do?
Idiot?
I...
I was the idiot.
Oh my god.
He's invisible.
Where is he?
Oh, I see him.
Wait, do I?
That's fucking right.
That's right.
I got you.
I got you now.
I see the water.
Oh, I see you.
Oh!
I don't see you!
This is so fucked up.
Oh my god!
Where are you?
Where is he?
He's over here.
Oh!
Nice!
Okay, I wasn't...
I didn't mean to do that, but that works out.
That actually works out for me.
Holy shit!
I didn't know that was his back.
Oh my god.
He's not there.
He's okay.
The fucking ghosts are not helping.
The ghosts are actually not helping me.
Because I'm like trying to figure out where he is.
But then like the ghosts are just flying everywhere.
And then I'm lost.
Okay, I need to make sure I don't...
No!
Where are you?
I'm trying not to show my back!
But I don't know where he is!
Because I'm thinking confused with Em- And the ghosts!
Oh my god.
Where are you fucking hitting my jellyfish?
Where?
He's over here.
Oh, he's over here.
I see you.
Oh, where's some water?
Oh my god he's...
Okay, right here.
You're right here.
That's fucking right.
Okay.
That's not fucking right.
Oh, he's looking for me, but I don't know where you are!
Okay.
There he is.
That's right, I got you!
I got you!
I got you, buddy!
Where is he?
Oh my god, there you are.
There you... What?
There you are.
There... Oh, there you are!
Yes!
It's like fucking... Where's Waldo?
Bro, that shit went so hard.
Okay, where's Waldo shit right there?
I... He's dead.
The evil has been defeated.
Oh my god.
A fucking coward.
This coward... Invisible shit.
Oh my god, we found him.
We found Waldo.
I look like... It's like some fucking... I'm fighting my inner demons right there.
Holy shit.
I would... If I had that ability, I would have done the same thing.
Holy fuck, that shit was crazy.
Are you sure he's real, Doki?
We don't... I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't see no black knife assassin.
Good job, Doki.
Way to go.
Thank you for the super chat, Kuro.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh... Tanu, thank you for the super chat.
Just got your CPI bot, man.
I presume you haven't died up to now.
Yeah!
Zero deaths.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
See?
My title is not alive.
Zero deaths, guys.
Are you sure that was a boss fight, Doki?
We didn't see anything.
Alright.
Thank God we had jellyfish.
I knew she was gonna be the best summons in that game.
Look at that.
My tanky-ass jellyfish.
North?
Oh, this way?
Alright.
I have no idea where I'm going.
I'm just walking along.
Alright.
No, the deaths on the bottom left is my jellyfish.
That's how many times she's died, not me.
We'll go this way.
I'm just keeping track of her deaths, guys.
I should put my lantern on.
Anything here?
Oh, wait.
Can you?
Oh my gosh, fuck this.
I don't care about it.
Too much.
Oh.
Make sure there's nothing here.
Oh, is that a cave?
Oh no, it's just an indent and a wall.
Unless!
Okay, no, it's not.
It's just actually an indent in the wall.
Alright.
I have no idea where the next story boss is.
I've just been walking around.
Alright.
I'll go this way.
It's a fake walls.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Oh my god!
I don't have, I don't have anything.
Oh my god.
I can't use the map.
Okay.
Bye.
Goodbye.
Don't worry.
I'll come back to you.
I just...
I realized I don't have mana.
I...
Surprise.
Alright.
Now, now, now go back.
Okay.
Now.
Now we can fight.
Alright.
Now we can do this.
Just like, hey.
Did anyone call an Uber?
He felt like a fucking Uber dragon right there.
I was like, whoa.
I wonder how this guy died.
And then I realized how he died.
Because I think I know how this guy died.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Please.
You're using up all my frames.
Oh my god.
My little guy already took half HP of damage.
Holy shit.
Guys, are you sure this guy's mandatory?
Are you guys sure?
Are you...
Are you guys sure he's mandatory again?
Oh my god.
My CPU is crying.
My CPU is crying right now.
My...
Holy shit.
I can't.
Every hit is like...
My entire HP.
Oh my god.
Oh, I think he wants to kill me.
Wait.
Put out some asbestos.
Wait, he's dead.
He's gone.
Wait, what?
Where did he go?
Just...
That's it?
They ran away?
Oh, pussy bitch.
Look at that.
See?
Zero deaths, guys.
I did it.
It was just a prank.
It's like...
Pocket...
Asbestos.
I won, guys.
He ran away.
So that's a win.
For me.
He was the one that ran away.
You got bone?
Wait, they don't even have bone.
Toki, the accent wasn't your fault.
Let the dragon go.
Sorry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, let's...
Get that grace.
Alright.
I don't think...
I don't think I'm like...
Near a story boss or anything.
I don't know.
It doesn't feel very story-esque.
Okay.
We need more bones for...
For arrows.
Because we're running out.
Okay.
Is there any shrine area yet?
Still don't know where to find a map for this place.
Uh...
Adam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you!
Comes and slaps you.
Then runs away.
What a guy!
Thank you for the super chat!
There's a church past the wall.
What?
Is there?
I said I didn't find the church.
I got atoned for my sins.
Oh, there it is.
I see it.
I see the maiden watching me.
It's behind me.
Hello, maiden.
Oh, it's her!
Oh my god.
I knew you were a gamer the moment I laid my eyes on you.
Wait, what?
Or take your hand?
Whoa!
Holding hands?
Oh my gosh.
I should do it.
Give me your hand.
I will pray that you follow the same path as Lady Tanith.
Oh my god.
We're going...
Guys, we're going second base, guys!
Help!
Second base!
Oh shit.
Volcano Manor?
Where am I?
Oh my god.
She took me to another maiden.
She took me to a lady.
That's third base.
Inviting a second person.
Brave tarnished.
Welcome to the Volcano Manor.
I am Tanith, the proprietress of this house.
Raya spoke well of you.
A warrior of promise.
I believe she said.
Perhaps you are prepared to make a commitment.
Will you join us here at the Volcano Manor?
I mean, like...
I can't really leave now.
She took me here.
...burden of their grace.
Or be fooled by the dogmatic ramblings of the fingers.
First base, our eyes meet.
Second base, we hold hands.
Third base, she invites...
She invites a second person.
Oh my god.
And then...
And then a home run.
She proposes.
Papa Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, do we...
Join the Volcano Manor?
Join the evil team?
Jokey, don't.
Wait.
Is there any other teams I can join?
Join?
Okay.
Don't do it yet?
Wait, why not?
There's one guy that says, Don't do it yet.
We get one guy.
It doesn't affect anything.
Alright.
There's no downside.
Nice.
Do it for her.
Okay, cool.
Make yourself comfortable.
But be sure to earn your keep.
Ooh.
Look at the drawing room.
Hello.
Wait, can I stab?
No, I can't stab here.
The drawing room is through the hole.
Alright.
Guys, I can't believe it.
Shoot.
I did it.
I got a home run, chat.
I guess it's up top.
Oh my god.
Be wary of weak fill.
Wait, there's somebody here?
Time for rolling.
Woo!
Wait, where's the weak fill?
Oh, is he like...
Wait, can I summon?
Oh, no summons.
Oh my god.
It's the fucking wheel.
I know this weapon.
Oh my god.
It's...
It's dead space all over again.
It's fucking dead space time.
Holy shit!
That does so much damage.
Pizza time.
Okay, it's fine.
What the fuck?
That's like one hit!
Yeah, I'm backing up after that.
Nice.
I know I'm faster.
Oh my god, never mind.
Okay.
I still know I'm faster though.
There we go.
There you go.
Pizza time.
That's right.
Give me your shit.
Yeah!
I tried to stand up on the table, but it wouldn't let me.
Likely clue.
Oh, is it the tree?
Alright.
That's right.
This time I knew for sure I'm faster.
I wish you could write your own message.
I'd be like pizza time.
I feel like everybody else would be like pizza time.
I-Fan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dead Space.
This doesn't mean you're going to use the best weapon.
The Joplin gun again.
Thank you for the super chat.
I-Fan, thank you.
Thank you.
Wait.
She like took me to this room.
And I don't know where to go.
Door is locked.
Oh yeah, there's this room.
Oh.
Free stuff.
Try running.
Perfume bottles.
Likely enemy?
They're here.
Where the fuck?
Oh, there.
Why are there snails here?
A ripper is it?
No!
The crew says thank you for the...
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I forgot, was it like every Akasupa I like...
I like used like...
It's like one shot or some shit.
One ammo.
Oh my god.
That shit was...
Trauma.
Lover ahead.
Oh, where is she?
Likely distracted.
Wait, where is she?
I opened this door, where is she?
I couldn't memorize.
It was 10 blades.
Oh yeah, 10 blades.
Oh, not here yet.
I was gonna say...
Did she like...
Blake out on my date?
Oh hey, I got a finger.
Oh, and a letter.
Where are you?
What name are you doing here?
The volcano...
I got invited.
Oh, she didn't pick you.
For the third person.
She picked me.
I hope you understand the weight of my words.
I don't understand.
Then you must leave immediately.
Oh, oops.
Those with weak stomachs have no place here.
Wait, I'm just stupid.
Wait.
Wait, I fucked up.
I thought he was gonna explain.
No.
Hello again.
Brave tarnished.
He was like, do you understand?
I was like, no, can you explain?
What?
I am pleased to see you again here.
I didn't think it was actually...
I thought choices don't matter.
Tarnished guidance.
May you tread the path of valor.
Brave tarnished.
I thought...
When the choices matter!
I thought I told you to leave.
I'm quite...
He didn't even let him finish.
When the choices matter!
Wait...
Don't worry.
He's gonna forget.
And then I can talk to him again.
Don't worry.
Okay.
I'll come back.
I understand now.
I thought I told you to leave.
What it means to be a recusant.
Renouncing grace.
And hunting down one's own.
Yes, I understand.
I'm sorry.
I was just...
I was just being a little stupid.
I'm sorry.
Yay!
There we go.
Alright.
Now we can go down the deep dark corridor.
Oh wait.
That's not it.
No.
Guys.
This can't be an evil manor.
Red is just a stylistic choice, guys.
Just a choice.
Oh, they're like evil snails.
They're like evil snails.
Okay.
We'll read the letters soon.
I just wanna kill these guys first.
I just wanna make sure there's nothing here before I read the letter.
Alright.
Where's this letter?
Okay.
As we're in a request, old...
He can be found in Limgrave.
Find the red mark on your map for the exact location.
Okay.
Yeah, they're not evil snakes.
They're stylistically...
It's just a choice.
Get rid of these guys first.
Let's try not to use up all my mana in case there is a boss.
Oh nice.
A cookbook.
Just in case.
I knew it.
I knew you were not real.
Oh wait.
What?
Did I kill you?
Wait, are...
Do you have to double kill you?
No.
Okay, they just showed up.
There's an item?
Oh, there it is.
Oh!
Whoops.
There's your chest ahead?
I can't open the door.
What do you mean?
I can't even open this door.
Oh, I don't have the right.
Okay.
Nice, I got more arrows.
This has to be fake.
Wait, it's not?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, that's a bait.
Alright, now we go down.
Said there was a boss, but like, you lied.
Where's your boss here?
Message ahead.
Strong foe ahead.
Oh wait, I think this is...
I think that's where the boss is.
Oh, there he is.
Okay, but what if I just do...
Okay.
Whoops.
I mean, not bad.
Look at that.
See?
Oh!
Wait, I don't think he can make it through.
Yeah, I think he's too thick.
Look, see?
Oh yeah, he's definitely too thick.
Look at him.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Can't do anything!
Ha ha!
Boy stuck!
He's stuck!
Look at him!
Ha ha ha!
He's so stuck!
I got the range!
You're too thick!
Boy!
Oh!
You're still too thick!
That's right!
Can't do anything about that!
Ha ha!
That TP all you want!
You're stuck!
How you gonna get through?
Okay.
I'm a little worried though.
Ha ha ha!
Faded!
Get faded, bitch!
Get fucking faded!
Ha ha ha!
Whoa!
Oh shit!
That's okay, I'm okay, guys.
Still too thick.
Oh!
Okay!
Uppercut it!
When he's never uppercut it before!
Holy shit!
What the fuck!
Okay, let me...
Okay, that's awkward.
What?!
How is he faster?!
Oh my god.
I don't know.
He's so much faster than me.
He's so much faster!
He does the counter!
It's okay.
Raise your hands, dragoons!
Give me your strength!
Give me your strength, dragoons!
Oh my god.
It's right here.
Okay.
This is like...
I know like...
Where his range is.
Cause like...
This is where his range is.
Thank you.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
So, as long as I'm...
Behind this red stain...
We should be fine.
Here we go.
Are you serious?!
He hits first?!
Oh my god!
He jumped!
Okay.
It's fine.
We got the cheese though.
We got the cheese.
It's alright.
That's it.
I know what to do.
Okay.
I don't have any left.
I...
Wait.
Do I not have any?
Okay.
I know what to do, guys.
I've learned.
Watch this.
Okay.
He has to get close to me.
Oh my god.
Please.
This is not fair.
Just stand in front.
Stand in front of me!
There you go.
Can't dodge this.
Can't dodge this!
That's right!
Oh.
I used it all up.
Okay.
One more hit.
There we go.
We did it!
The most badass fight of all time.
The most engaging, exciting fight we've ever seen.
Okay.
Time for Grace.
Oh, there's a Grace in front of me.
Nice.
What an epic battle, guys.
It was so engaging.
Okay.
That was the liar.
Let me...
Let me vote that as poor.
And then vote this as good.
I don't know if I got tricked, everyone shall get tricked.
Everyone must make the same mistake as me!
I don't know.
Oh, I do.
Okay.
We get entrance up.
The cycle never ends!
We could say it was a Gouda fight without cheese it was.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We continue the cycle!
Where am I?
Oh, this is our house.
Welcome to the Legacy Dungeon?
What's that mean?
Visions of Head.
Okay, I soon went to go to that area.
Alright, I guess I go down.
Cause I don't know...
Oh!
What the fuck?
Oh, is this where the Magma Worm is?
Like, he's so alive.
What was he calling for?
Wait, is his friend supposed to come over?
Like, what was he calling for?
Oh my god, there's so many people on the roofs.
There's a lever somewhere.
I don't remember where.
But it's there.
There's someone here.
And there's someone to my right.
Oh, there's dogs here.
Oh, you know what?
Fuck this.
Fuck.
There you go.
Yeah, I'm not dealing with that.
You can.
Man.
I don't wanna deal with dogs.
Right now.
You got this jellyfish.
Oh my god.
Okay, you still got this.
I believe in you.
Block, body, block, block all of this.
Okay.
Okay, maybe the jellyfish was a little overkill.
Maybe.
I don't think we needed the jellyfish, guys.
It could have been a little bit of an overkill.
You wear a lovable sword?
Where?
Oh, him?
Oh, wait.
Isn't that the...
Oh!
I saw this on!
Elden Ring Shorts!
Come over here, baby.
I'm looking for a good time.
Yeah, come on.
I'm looking for a...
Oh!
Shit!
Come on, baby.
Put me inside you!
Come on!
Eat me!
Yeah!
Let me in!
This was in my Elden Ring Shorts!
Come on, girl!
I can rock your world!
Open that mouth up!
Oh, shit!
Wait, not in this area?
Okay, goodbye!
Apparently...
Apparently it's not here.
Sorry, wrong one!
Wrong one!
I was...
I'm looking for someone else!
I'm looking for Jenny!
This one just kills you, Toki!
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
Can I, like...
Whoa!
It's a different Samoyed!
Jesus Christ.
It's fine.
Sorry.
I was looking for Jenny.
Whoops.
No, I, like, saw it in my Elden Ring...
Like, it was in my Elden Ring Shorts algorithm.
Because for some...
I'm getting, like, Elden Ring stuff now for my Shorts algorithm.
And it was like, oh, if you wanna get this weapon, you just have to get eaten by an Iron Maiden.
In the...
Volcano Manor.
And I was like, there she is.
I'm ready.
Oh!
Fuck!
Not for that!
That's not what I meant when I said I'm ready.
Jesus!
No!
My Ravens!
Alright.
Okay.
Let me figure out how to get my shit back.
Oh, there he goes again.
How can I backstab this guy?
Alright, get down from there.
Okay, okay, my runes...
Oh, thank God it's above.
Thank God it's up there.
Okay.
That's good.
That's actually really good for me.
I don't know how I whiffed that, but that's okay.
Where do I go?
This area is so...
Oh, shit.
There's so much stuff here.
No!
What?!
Did you just do that?!
Where did he go?
Well, he just disappeared.
He like, ate me and then left.
He's like, I did my job.
He's like, oh, I thought you wanted a good time.
He's like, I'm Jenny.
Wait, he's like, didn't you ask for Jenny?
That's me.
Yeah.
I actually don't know where to go.
Go here?
Oh, maybe here.
Oh, it's here.
I'm pretty sure.
Cause it's like, there's stairs up here.
I still have to go to this castle.
Okay, I think I made it.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, I just take that.
Try fall, but zero deaths.
Thank you for the super chat laughing.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, that doesn't count.
Because technically, like, I didn't die to an enemy.
Jenny?
And...
Okay, let's use it.
Yeah, I can't get...
Wait, is it her?
Jenny?
Wait, let me...
Is that you?
No.
Where will I find Jenny?
Behold ladder.
Wait, what?
Wait, why she got mad?
Oh my god.
Wait, I thought...
I thought she was friendly!
They said she was friendly!
Oh, is that any good?
Let's go here.
Actually, I wanna...
Grab this XP anyway.
Might as well.
Yeah, they do 300, so they're pretty good.
But I don't think Jenny knows...
I don't think she knows how to...
Go upstairs.
Yeah, she doesn't.
So I can stay here.
Jenny is in the nerd castle elevator where you avoided...
Wait, who's gravity guy?
I don't remember...
Guys, you gotta be specific.
I avoided a lot of people.
Thank you for the super chat, Saika.
Thank you, thank you.
I avoided so many people.
You gotta be more specific.
Keep there.
Oh, at the school.
Purple magic guy?
Okay, you gotta be more specific.
No!
Fuck!
I got distracted again.
Okay.
That could be anyone.
I know.
So many people wanna kill me.
It could be any one of these people.
Oh my god.
I'm okay.
Okay.
I'm so healthy.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Where did this sound?
Why is this sound, man?
It's so fucking strong!
Oh
my god.
Oh my god.
Okay, it doesn't help that like...
That lag there.
That stutter there.
Oh, do they...
This area is making me stutter so much too.
Like this particular area.
I don't think I've had like, such bad stutters.
Before.
Hey guys, did I miss anything?
I'm trying to find Jenny.
So I can like, hop inside and rock her world, Bandai.
Yeah.
Yeah, zero deaths so far.
Is that her?
Jenny, is that you?
Oh shit!
No!
Found her sister.
Free item!
Free item, let's go!
Let's go!
Oh wait, there's another item here.
Okay.
Oh my god, please tell me there's a Grace nearby.
Okay, there are three people hanging out.
Hang out.
Nimble sword ahead.
Oh my god, I have to use Arrows Donut.
Okay.
Alright, I got this.
Wait, what's wrong with him?
Are they okay?
It's okay, guys.
It's just a flesh wound.
Is it worth killing them?
I don't even know if that was worth killing them.
No, they're not okay.
What the fuck?
How are they hitting me?
They can't even move!
Oh my god, I have nothing.
No more flask.
I have no more flask.
Oh, this is bad.
What are they doing?
They're just praying.
The fuck are they doing?
Okay.
Oh.
Can't even.
Move!
Okay, nice.
We need the lantern because I can't see shit.
Fear ahead.
Monstrosity ahead.
Where?
Oh my god, please tell me there is a...
Please tell me.
Please tell me there's like a grace somewhere.
God, I just need one grace.
That's right.
No more praying for you.
Hey there.
Hi.
I can't really do anything.
Oh my god!
Okay, I got baited there.
Guys, please.
I can't slowly die from poison.
Please don't do this to me.
There's one below but beware of ambush.
God damn it.
There's always ambush.
Guys, I'm just fine.
It's just like...
It's just a little poison guys.
I'm fine.
I ate some random berries but it's okay.
I can poop it out.
That's how it works, right?
Guys, please.
I'm slowly dying.
Please.
Message a...
Message a praise.
I'm slowly dying.
Guys, I have no grace near me.
Please.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, I'm just one HP.
It's alright.
I can live through this.
It's just a flesh wound.
I'm so healthy.
What?
They can't move now?
Oh!
Guys!
Guys, they can't move!
Please!
Message a praise!
Man, he's on my tail!
He's right behind me, isn't he?
He's right!
Oh!
That's okay.
He can't get through this.
I have a pillar.
Guys!
He's gonna touch me and I'll be dead!
Okay.
It's okay.
He can't...
Oh my god.
It's not okay.
He can't jump!
Ha ha ha!
That's a great...
Idiot!
He can't jump!
What you gonna do now?
Look at you!
Stupid!
Ha ha ha!
You can't do jack shit!
The wall is in front of you!
Ha ha ha!
Oh my god!
Okay!
I mean...
I gotta be careful here.
Okay, there we go.
Ha ha!
Me and the wall!
My hero!
Ha ha ha!
Look at that!
I live.
Got the wall on my side.
There's grace below the staircase.
Guys!
I am like...
Living by the thread right now.
Oh god.
I hear them.
I hear them growling.
They know.
They know!
They fucking know!
Okay, guys.
Come on.
Here you...
Ha ha ha!
Please.
I have an extra message.
Just...
Just come here!
Just don't get it!
Okay.
There's one right here.
That's where it is.
It's right there, right?
It's...
It's right there.
Right?
Is it right there?
Oh my god.
They're all there.
Please.
I just...
Oh my god.
Okay.
I can make it now.
Like I said, right.
Wait.
Where is it?
Do you mean my left?
Oh my god.
It was my left side.
That is incredible.
Oh.
Oh!
Okay.
It's fine.
I have the HP.
Okay.
It's fine.
I'm not scared anymore!
That's fucking right!
I'm not scared of anything!
Okay.
That has to be the grace.
Oh!
I made it.
I fucking made it.
Shit.
I faced my fears!
I told you how to raise your hands!
Thank fucking god!
Okay.
I think I can have one more level up.
Alright.
Yeah, I can use this.
And then...
Endurance.
I think it is like endurance to 20, right?
Praise the sun!
Now I go this way.
Woo!
Shortcut!
To your death!
What is this shortcut?
I mean, I could just go down here.
Do not go down there!
Go back up!
Floor is lava!
There's some very angry things down there.
Never mind.
I like being up here.
Downstairs is danger.
What item?
I actually don't know if I should be going...
I like how I'm full HP and now I'm...
Now...
Now I'm getting...
Getting the fucking appraisals.
You fuckers.
You guys were waiting for it this entire time!
You fuckers!
Oh, I have to go downstairs?
God dammit.
Okay.
Is there an item?
Oh, there is.
It only took one person to break.
Okay, we have to go downstairs.
All it takes was one guy.
Oh my god.
I missed the map.
The map was all the way over there.
It's good.
We don't need the map!
We don't need navigate...
Oh my god.
I don't have my horse.
Okay.
I don't know what to do.
No center.
Okay.
We can run past all of this.
Wee!
Okay, we don't need that item.
It's not that important.
Alright, we go this way.
Wait, was that the shortcut?
No, I've never been here before.
What the fuck?
What is that?
That's a new weapon.
He has a new weapon.
Oh shit!
He's whipping me!
Oh!
Please!
No!
I rolled into everything!
I...
Oh my god!
I panicked!
He started whipping me!
He's seriously like, Get back to work!
I was like, No!
I don't wanna go back to work!
Please!
I just wanna play Marvel Rivals!
Okay.
Oh my god, guys.
Sorry.
My screen closed there for a second.
But I saw zero deaths.
Oh my god!
My fucking toe touched.
Guys, it's technically still zero deaths, guys.
Alright.
My screen closed for a second.
But I assume I live.
What was the plan there?
That's a good question.
I...
No!
Please!
I don't wanna go back to...
No!
Who will win?
One fucking lizard with a whip.
I don't know.
Oh my god!
It's like, PTSD or some shit.
I...
I don't know why!
This one...
I didn't die to any other boss, but this one guy...
He just has a whip!
There's just something about him!
His aura!
Cus, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Kaffily Toki's manager is in the game.
Uh, Thomas, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I was gonna say, don't die, but you did.
No, no, zero deaths, guys.
Still zero deaths.
Oh my god, there's just something about him.
That just... fucks me up.
Okay, I can roll this.
I can roll this.
Haha, your whip is not long enough here.
Okay, it was long enough.
Okay, it's fine.
Please, it's just one more hit.
Okay, we did it.
And then his buddy is slowly walking over, but I see you.
I fucking see you.
Alright.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
What is he doing here?
This guy is new?
AHHHHH!
You can stay there.
Fuck you.
Up ahead in the shortcut.
Okay.
Looks like your Influencer build is hitting a wall.
Maybe you need a respect.
Maybe, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, technically I didn't die if I closed my eyes.
Okay, we're not going for that guy.
That guy feels like he might fuck me up.
There has to be a shortcut here somewhere.
Okay, nice.
Likely down.
Something ahead.
Here?
Oh, the shortcut is past him.
Okay.
Alright.
I don't understand.
Why can't I bring my...
Bring my horse?
We're outside.
Professor Oak can't stop me.
Oh my god.
He's literally just running at me.
Okay, we're running.
I wanna open the shortcut first.
Wait, where's the shortcut?
Wait.
Wait, where is it?
Oh my god.
He put me in a corner!
He actually trapped me in the corner!
Holy shit!
Okay, it's on the left.
It's on the left.
He like...
Okay.
Oh my god.
That's fire.
That's the boss room!
I'm in the boss room!
Oh my fuck!
Oh shit!
I thought what you said go left!
I thought you meant inside left!
Oh no.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
I accidentally used it.
I keep accidentally thinking it's B instead of...
Oh my god.
It's okay.
My little bungee's here.
He's here.
He's here now.
Get me outta here.
Oh my god.
This is very awkward.
We gotta stop running into each other like this.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
He faded me!
I thought he was gonna try and kill the jellyfish!
But then he turned around!
He knew what I wanted to do!
Jesus Christ.
How do I get out of these flames?
Okay.
Oh my god.
This is scary.
Bro, like, he does this!
He looks at him!
And then he turns around!
He's like, Oh, you thought I was trying to...
Fucking stupid!
Oh my god.
It's not fair!
Wait.
I can just be here.
That works.
I'll take that.
You know...
I'll take it.
I need every advantage...
I didn't even intentionally cheese that.
It just works.
Oh my god!
Please!
Message of praise.
Message of praise!
Guys!
Just one!
I just... Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
We're so... Guys, how about another one, though?
How about another message of praise?
Guys, just another one, please.
Just another one.
Just to be safe.
Just to be safe, guys.
Just one more.
I thought it would work again.
I thought it would work, please.
Just one more.
Chad, just one more.
I beg of you, please.
Please, guys.
I just need one more.
Please.
I just need to survive long enough.
The poison.
Just let me survive long enough.
Oh!
I beg of you!
One!
One massive surprise!
Just one!
I just need one!
I can't!
I'm so low!
One.
That's all I... Okay.
You fuckers!
I just need one more!
Oh my god!
It was actually... It was so low!
It was so low!
Oh!
I... Oh!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you for the message of praise!
Thank you!
I really needed that!
Oh man!
Thanks, guys!
It's not my day.
Live by the Influencer Pills.
Die by the... Oh my god!
And he's waiting for me too.
Oh my god, this time it'll be different.
This time.
You feel it now, Mr. Krabs.
Oh, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's so fucked up.
Alright, the left side.
Oh, I see the shortcut this time.
It's right here.
I see it.
It's okay, it'll take a while to get back to me.
Okay, now we have the shortcut.
I got you, Doki.
Message appraised.
Thank you for the super chat.
Okay, does this guy respawn?
I need to know.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
I am.
Does he respawn or does he not?
Sorry.
He does?
Okay.
Alright.
There better be a fucking grace in front of me.
Alright, I'm gonna go here and see if there's a grace.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, thank god.
Thank fucking god.
I don't have to go through the fucking whip anymore.
You fuckers.
Wait, actually...
Is there like...
Okay, where's...
Is there a word...
Is there appraisal here?
Wait, where's appraisal?
First...
First off, time for message.
There we go.
Time for message.
Here we go.
Oh, I hate that you can't...
I can't believe it.
I think this is so fucked up.
I think it was literally like one hit.
It's so fucked up.
I needed one message appraised.
No, I didn't need to play my...
Oh my god, not the ladder.
No.
Oh my god, though.
Thank you for the body block.
Actual W body block right there.
Holy shit.
What a fucking hero.
What a hero right there.
Oh my god, a real hero.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, okay.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, I just dodged it.
Where is my...
Where did I die?
Oh, I died here.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
My jellyfish relocated.
Jesus Christ, that hits me.
What is this?
What is this range?
Holy fuck, that range was crazy.
That was a crazy range.
Now I know I have to get there.
Okay, it's 2,000.
It's not that much anyway.
I don't really care about the 2,000.
I don't know what it is about this world.
Wait, let me look at my settings.
But it's just like...
What it is about this world where I stutter even more than usual.
That hitbox is fucking crazy.
He was one shot though.
He just don't get hit next time.
Yeah, it's just...
Just don't get hit.
It's the lava?
Oh, maybe.
Yeah, there's something about this particular enemy that does so much.
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's fine.
Okay, nice.
Get baited, bitch.
Ha ha!
Get baited.
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh, shit!
I got baited!
Okay.
Okay, I'm backing out.
Fuck you.
Okay, he's poisoned.
That's good.
Okay, maybe it'll work this time.
No!
I did not replicate it!
It was so good!
I wish I could!
I wish I could replicate whatever I did there.
When I fucking...
managed to like...
When he started rolling into that...
Oh my god.
That was so good.
I don't know how to replicate it though.
I wish I could, guys!
I was actually gaming when that happened.
Okay.
Here we go.
I don't know his patterns.
I need to figure out his patterns more.
What?
He cheated!
He's just rolling around me!
Shit!
Okay, that doesn't go through.
I hate him.
Oh my god.
I hate him so much.
I'm...
I'm so...
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
This guy.
This guy's a fucker.
Okay.
Back off.
I'm backing up.
I'm backing up!
I give you personal space!
What more do you want from me?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh my god, bro.
Bro.
Oh my god.
Oh, is he dead?
Is he dead?
Oh, I did it!
Oh, thank god for...
for message of praise!
Thank god!
Oh!
The message...
Thank god I have six health bars!
I don't even know if I've ever had this!
Is he a story boss?
I'll never know!
No!
Alright.
Four!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Before you complete the Volcano Manor, make sure to do a letter side quest.
Lady Tanerath has you...
be a bounty hunter, kill people for loot.
Five possible, but you killed Patches low, so only four now!
Oh, we won't tell!
Okay, let me see if I can like...
Where's the graphics settings?
Where is it?
Maybe it's like...
Okay, off...
Advanced settings...
There...
Oh!
Okay, I think I know now.
Okay, guys, what do we turn off?
What do we turn off?
Okay, okay, that explains a lot.
Maybe now it will...
Okay, guys, we found the root of the problem.
It only took us four parts.
It only took us like a couple...
Like, I don't know.
Ten plus hours.
Alright, guys.
What do...
Okay, let's put everything on high first.
Maybe that'll be better.
Okay.
Okay, we gotta return.
Let's return to the title real fast.
Let's...
Okay, let's make sure we...
Okay, things make a little more sense now.
Okay.
It only took 15 hours, chat.
Just 15 hours to figure this out.
Oh, shadows and water to medium.
Okay.
Okay, was that fight...
I don't even remember if that fight stuttered that much in general.
Okay, we can turn effects and grass.
and then we go back to the title.
Are you going to be at the game before the dllc or after the dllc?
I don't have the dlc.
Uh let me give you.
I only said like what?
Seven story bosses.
Thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They real.
Thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You barely touch grass.
What do you mean?
No, I remember I adjusted the settings before.
I think, like, when I downgraded my drivers, it, like, reset all my graphic settings again.
Because I remember I, like, uh, I adjusted it before.
Okay.
Yeah?
I'm gonna be, like, Rock Lee taking off of those weights.
Thank you, Super Chat toasting.
Thank you.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna make it to a story, boss.
I don't know, I haven't died yet.
If I close my eyes every time, then I've never died.
I didn't see my death, so I never died.
No treasure chest, therefore no arm, armaments ahead.
Why am I here?
Wait, this entire place?
Golden runes.
I guess it's for level up.
Oh, wait, I can level up.
Oh, I didn't- I forgot I killed a boss just now.
Oh my god, I need to make sure not to jump down.
Yeah, I'm- I can't figure out where the elevator is.
Alright.
Okay.
We got endurance up.
And we need 20- Do I have enough for 20k?
Let's check.
Uh, 6k.
Oh, I think- Do.
Yeah.
There you go.
Alright.
Wait, how much was it?
No, I actually need to do one more rune.
Alright, what do we do next after endurance?
Because I remember you guys said, like, up to 20k?
Dexterity, okay.
Okay, now I should have enough.
Alright.
Okay, where do we go after here?
Okay.
Alright.
We'll do one more boss and then I'll call it for today.
Uh...
Go outside?
Go back to the other elevator?
There's another elevator?
Oh, there's another door in the bottom.
Oh, it's the other magma worm.
Okay, I'll go back down.
Oh, that one.
That door, okay.
This one.
Lever!
No horse ahead?
It has to be here.
Wait, it does not move.
Jump down from second level?
Here?
Oh.
Yeah, that's dead end.
Why'd this guy die?
Oh, that's a shortcut?
Oh!
Oh, outside the boss room.
Okay.
I have to go back to the whip snake?
Him?
God damn it.
Hello.
I killed your boss.
Pretty bad at...
Or a pretty bad bodyguard.
Not gonna lie.
You here?
Is this one?
Where am I?
Oh, hey.
There's an item.
Oh, there he is.
That's right.
I have jellyfish.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
It's okay.
I'm okay.
I am not okay.
I am not...
Wait, he doesn't even have a boss safe...
This guy's not
even...
This is a non...
No one said...
I said we're gonna fight a boss.
And then why?
Okay, it's because I...
I tactically stopped fighting him.
Because I realized he wasn't a boss.
So I stopped fighting him.
It was tactical.
Okay, is it here?
No, I...
Willingly stopped fighting him.
What the fuck am I?
Oh.
Second floor balcony.
Okay.
Here?
Madness, oh madness.
Where do I jump?
Here?
Oh, I guess I jump here.
Hello.
Hey, guys.
Friendly?
Come on, guys.
I'm one of you.
Whoa.
Whoa!
Oh, God.
These guys are definitely not friendly.
Whoa!
Okay, we're fine.
Let's have to parkour a little.
Okay, not here.
Hey, where do I go?
Because these guys do not look friendly.
Whoa!
To the right.
Oh, right here.
I see it.
I see the tunnel.
Alright.
Here we go.
I guess I...
Drop down.
Alright.
There's no horse ahead.
Oh.
Where am I?
Wait, I'm back here.
God!
I went back.
I dropped down.
I'm so lost.
I hate this place.
Why did I join her stupid cult?
Why didn't she give me a map after I joined her goddamn stupid fucking cult?
Okay.
Okay, guys.
Give me a detailed instruction on where to go.
Let's use cardinal directions.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There's southwest, north, and east.
Where...
East.
Okay.
I'll go east.
Wait, east and jump down?
But that's a cliff.
Here?
Oh, here!
Oh, I didn't see that.
I didn't see the little nook right there.
Okay.
Now we're here.
And then I parkour.
Oh my god.
No, it's her.
Oh my god, it's her.
Okay.
We made it.
Where the...
What?
Oh!
Oh my god.
I'm...
Oh!
Oh my god!
I missed the one hole.
I missed the one fucky hole.
Okay, I just want to be sure what's down there.
Okay, now I'm here.
Where the fuck am I?
Wait, she...
He has a...
He has a lava sword.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh my god, I'm on fire.
I'm on fire.
It's fine.
At least it's not a whip.
Thank god, it's not a whip.
Okay, nice.
Wait, have I been here before?
Wait, I got a rare drop?
I didn't even notice that.
It's just that easy.
What can I say?
I'm just that good.
Oh, it's right here.
It's that good, guys.
He got the first drop.
I'm just kidding.
What can I say?
Oh, this is back to the church.
Oh, I got the shortcut.
Yeah, look at that.
First try.
You guys want to see it?
Look at that.
The man's surface shield.
Some people drown while others die of thirst.
You want to see it?
It just took me one try to get this.
And what?
Like it's hard or something?
Maybe I should sell it, too.
Yeah.
What?
Like it was hard or something, guys?
No big deal.
Just a silly sword.
Oh, my God.
I almost thought he was going to eat me again.
There we go.
What if I just get it again?
Can you get it double?
It might be fucked up if I just get it again, you know?
Oh, he does like poison damage when he dies.
Oh, I didn't even see that.
Oh, my God.
God damn it.
I thought I could roll it in.
Wait, that's a 1% drop?
Wait, it's 0.5.
You know I don't deserve that, too.
I did not deserve that drop as well.
That's the most fucked up fight.
And I won.
You know?
Oh, shit.
It's a fire.
Shit.
It's a fire whip.
Oh, my God.
That's it.
I'm using him.
Oh, my God.
I don't care.
I cannot deal with...
I cannot deal with fire and whip at the same time.
Oh, my God.
I gloated too much.
I need to make sure I don't die to him.
I glo...
I have to make sure I can't die to him.
I'm already gloated too much.
I already gloated too much.
I can't die to him.
For the sake...
For the sake of this stream.
Nice.
I lived.
Behold, precious item.
Where?
Is there one here?
Or maybe here?
No?
It's down?
I don't want to go down.
It looks so dangerous, though.
Okay, let's see if there's a grace here.
And then I'll think about going down.
Oh, there's a shortcut.
Oh.
It's not...
Straight up, there's a room.
Okay.
How worth it is it?
Okay, I...
Like, I'm feeling a little scared to trust you guys.
Because I may or may not have gloated a bit too much.
And I feel like you guys want me to die.
I feel like...
I have a feeling you guys want me to die.
I don't know.
I don't know why I feel that.
May or may not...
I've been a little too cocky.
Okay, I got rollo in.
What the fuck?
Where did he come from?
I'll get rid of the poison guys first.
Good job, Jellyfish.
For getting up.
For distracting him.
Appreciate it.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
What the fuck is that?
There's two of them.
I don't even know.
Oh, I have to not beat him?
Alright, Gordon.
They give us a super chat.
Thank you.
This one?
Oh, hey.
Is this a dungeon?
What's over here?
Oh, I don't have enough.
God damn it.
I need two.
Grace close?
Where's the grace?
Past that guy?
Oh, it's past this portal?
Or past this church?
Oh, okay.
Oh, I need the key door.
Or fight.
Okay, I'll just fight him.
I might just run.
I mean...
Wait, what the fuck?
Why can't...
Oh.
Okay, I'll just run.
Oh my god, it's a nerd.
That's why he has such a big head.
That's where he stores all his magic.
Bye.
Okay.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, so I shouldn't fight him.
Okay.
Alright.
Let me upgrade.
Let's see if I have any upgrades, actually.
Let's try and...
Jesus Christ, this map is huge.
Wait, am I supposed to...
Do a side quest first?
Go to a red spot.
Okay.
I'll go to the red spot.
Let me upgrade my stuff first.
I think I have enough to upgrade.
Oh, I do.
Yay!
My jellyfish is so strong now.
How about...
Okay, I need...
Fuck, I need six of those.
Because I don't have that.
Alright.
We'll do the side quest.
And then we'll call it then.
Where's the big red mark?
Is it these?
Oh, is side quest long?
Is it that?
Okay, never mind.
We'll call it here then.
It's incredibly long.
Because I know...
I remember this bridge.
That's where all the giant fucking trollers are.
Oh, I can't finish the side quest.
The other areas are locked.
Is it locked?
Okay, we'll...
We'll do the boss though.
We'll do the boss then.
If it's locked.
Where was it?
Okay.
Uh...
Wait, then what do I do?
People are saying I don't have the area yet.
Some people say I don't...
I don't have the area unlocked yet.
So do I do it or not?
I don't have the side quest.
But if I can't finish the side quest, then...
How do I finish side quest if one is unlocked?
What do I get out of it, chat?
Do I actually get something where I will actually change my equipment into?
Or is it just a collection?
Do I actually get something where I will actually use?
Or...
Or will I...
You just...
Yeah, but is it better than my katana right now?
A whip and a quilt...
Okay, but is the arm...
Is the armor better than what I have now?
But like, look at me.
I'm a fancy-ass knight.
Is it better than this armor?
Cool katana!
Okay, but is it better than this katana?
Looks-wise...
Look, I...
We're not here but looks.
We're here...
Stat-wise...
I just don't want to die.
Is it...
Is it better...
Stat-wise...
Is it better than this armor?
We're not here but drip, okay?
We're not here about drip.
We're here about stats.
We need to know.
Oh, wrong game for that ad.
I just want to be alive!
That's not what I want.
You put the drip, Toki.
Okay, we'll do...
Does the quest have a boss?
There's actually a way to get along in katana if you're interested.
Okay, but is it katana for nerds or is it katana for like...
Cool...
Cool bros like me.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No?
Okay, then we'll call it here.
I was gonna end on a boss but if there's no nearby boss then we'll call it here.
Alright.
I'm gonna call it here everybody.
I hope you guys enjoyed today's playthrough.
I can't guys!
People don't want me to lock my quest.
So we can't do this boss.
Because apparently if I do this boss it'll lock me out of a quest.
So, uh, we can't do it.
I know it's just begging for me to kill it too.
He's like right there.
He's like, come on, you know you wanna stab me.
Come on, come on, you know you want me to wanna stab.
You're so close to it.
I can't.
I can't stab him.
Unfortunately.
Uh...
Right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for the stream, Toki.
I'm sorry, I swear it wasn't on purpose.
Anyway, the outfit looks great.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright guys, we're gonna call it here.
Because we're gonna have a long Halo stream next time, tomorrow.
Uh, I don't know how I'll finish Halo tomorrow.
But we'll see how many chapters we can get.
But thank you all for coming everybody.
Um, after my birthday next week.
We can have, um, Zatsudon streams again.
Because now I can finally chill.
Um, I'm trying not to like use up too much of my voice.
Because I still have some more stuff to do.
Like recording wise.
And like practicing for the concert and everything.
Which sucks.
Because I really want to like talk to you guys more after.
Like post game streams.
But after my birthday, I can do post game.
Like post game Zatsudons again.
Anyway guys.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get everyone around to get that blood flowing.
And if you suffer me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.